actor Bill Cosby is expected to learn
his punishment this week for drugging
and sexually assaulting a woman at his
home
Cosby's sentencing hearing begins later
this morning the 81 year old comedian
was convicted in April of three counts
of aggravated indecent assault and now
faces up to 30 years in prison more than
60 women have accused Bill Cosby of
sexual misconduct one of his accusers
spoke at a news conference yesterday in
Philadelphia I pray it's 30 years he
deserves every year we all suffered a
lot Jericka Duncan is outside the
Montgomery County Courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania with what to
expect later today
Jericka good morning good morning that
sentencing hearing expected to begin
shortly but look behind me people
already lined up to get in the courtroom
some of those women are women who have
accused Bill Cosby of sexual assault in
the past now the man known as America's
dad was convicted in April of drugging
and molesting Temple University
administrator former Temple University
administrator andrea constand while at
his philadelphia home back in 2004
Cosby's criminal case began nearly three
years ago the first trial in June of
2017 ended and a mistrial after a jury
failed to reach a unanimous verdict now
the judge could sir could sentence Cosby
to as many as 10 years in prison for
each of the three counts for each of the
three counts he was convicted of for a
possible total of 30 years although
state guidelines call for a base 22 to
36 months behind bars now Cosby's
lawyers are expected to request to keep
the 81 year-old at home because of his
age and health problems Cosby has been
at home since his conviction on house
arrest and Cosby this entertainer
comedian no
- so many people will be the first
person sentenced during this me -
movement era Nora
alright tarika thank you